Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't ha-
What the fuck am I doing?
No, really, what the fuck am I doing?
I'll tell you what I'm doing: Scooby Doo, the douche-horse movie!
[hip-hop version of the Scooby Doo theme plays]
Yeah, fuck it. Here's what I think of the movie:
IT FUCKING SUCKS. The end!
No no no I wouldn't...do that to you, but, at the same time...
Is this it? I-Is this really life?
No! This isn't life! This isn't anything even representing life! But it's life for me!
It's pretty pathetic, but...it's all I got!
I know what you're saying, "Wow that's pretty sad," well you know what, yeah, it IS fucking sad!
I don't get to go out and hang out with friends, I don't even HAVE any friends!
I have nobody to contribute anything to, I have nobody to talk to or bounce things off of, you know?
It's not like "Hey, what do you think of that?" "I'll tell you what I think of this," no! It's just me bitching and moaning like I always do!
And some would say "Well that's a pretty sad existence!" well yeah it is a pretty sad existence
just SITTING HERE AND WATCHING SCOOBY FUCKING DOO!
[becoming hysterical] I mean for God's sakes! I've never done anything!
I've never done anything to make someone's life better!
Or-or-or-or-or gone and play game with somebody! I would LOVE to play a game with somebody!
Wouldn't it be great? I mean somebody is just like: "Oh hey what'chu doing? Want to play this game with us?"
"What game?" "Punch-Easy"
I don't know what the fuck people are playing but you know what? It would be nice!
It would be nice to be invited! I-I have never even gone to a...bar with somebody!
Hang around with some friends! I haven't even gone to a.. a stripclub!
Okay, I've gone to a couple of stripclubs but I have never gone with anybody!
I've never been there- and actually been like-
-okay not with people, but still! You know what? It'd be nice!
It'd be nice just ONE DAY to go somewhere, where somebody is just having a good time,
and somebody just says: "I don't where-"
"Hey you know what? That guy was okay! Not great, but he was okay!
Instead of: "Hey, who was that little FUCKSHIT?!"
Well, I'll TELL you who that FUCKSHIT IS! He is the NOSTALGIA CRITIC, HE REMEMBERS IT SO YOU DON'T FUCKING HAVE TO!
Even though EVERY. FUCKING. DAY HE EXISTS, he WISHES he didn't have to!
He WISHES he didn't have to do this BULLSHIT to make you WATCH, and get you ratings!
And WHY does it happen?! Why do you keep coming back?! Because YOU'RE FUCKING SICK, AND I'M FUCKING STUPID!
THAT'S THE WAY IT IS! That's the way it's ALWAYS GONNA BE! THERE IS NO CHANGE!
THERE IS NO FUTURE! THERE'S NO PAST! The present is a JOKE! Everything is HELL!
My life is HELL! THIS is the worst THING, a HUMAN BEING, could ever, GO THROUGH!
[Pure enraged screaming]
So let's start, uh..
This is where I
usually show up
you clips from the trailer because I was too lazy to find any actual clips that are visually interesting for you.
And I of course talk over it. I mean, what's the point in trying to change anything, right?
I am where I am. Nothing's going to
make it any different.
[Sigh]
It's not like I can just go back in time and alert my young self of the HELL that awaits him.
[Time Warping SFX]
Alright! Scooby Doo, the Movie. This is gonna be so clever and-
[Both getting surprised]
What the hell?
Holy shit!
It's like looking into the future!
Is that me from the past?
Oh! Hey, does the internet ever become anything? Or do we still just use it for porn?
It's porn, isn't it?
Wait a minute, this doesn't make any sense. How am I able to talk to my younger self?
I don't know, maybe it has something to do with the fact I'm about to watch the awesome Scooby-Doo movie!
It's great because I remember Scooby-Doo existed and this movie remembers that Scooby-Doo existed, so it's really tapping into my childhood-...
What's the word I'm looking for?
Nostalgia?
Nah, that's not it..
Well look, younger me, what ever you do, don't watch that piece of crap.
What? But they said it's a satirical hip new look at the characters I know and love!
But it's not done well! It's just a corporate sellout.
Oh then forget it! I hate corporate sellouts.
They're all narcs, they can all just kiss my ass!
Hey by the way, what's it like making put bazillions of dollars selling your ideas?
Uh.. yeah about that..
Um, a little word of advice from your future self, uh.. you may not wanna keep making those videos.
What? Why not?
Trust me, they're not as good as you think they are.
Well, what the hell do you know, you stupid close-minded narc?
I'm you, you dumbass!
Yeah? Well, how do I know the corporation's didn't get to you?
How do I know they didn't find you and like brainwash you into talking to your younger self convincing me not to make the greatest movies of all time?
Ugh, look,
I'm not making this up, listen to me. This is totally believable.
You need to stop because Mara Wilson, the little girl from Mrs. Doubtfire is going to find them and blackmail you with them years later.
Dude, that seriously the best you could come up with?
Oh my god, if only you could] see the future so you can understand what's in store for you.
[Time Warping SFX]
[Both of them are surprised]
Awesome!
What are you doing here? What am I doing here? What's going on here?
I don't know,
It's like all these different parts in my life are coming together: The past,
present and future! All I wanted to do was just watch the fucking Scooby-Doo movie!
Wait! I was going to put it on, too.
My memory of Scooby-Doo is so bad, I was going to put it on to see if I can remember it. Heurgh.
But wait, both I and the young me we're gonna watch it, too.
Great, zzzzz-God..
We're all gonna watch the same movie.
Yeah, so?
And yet somehow it caused a temporal anomaly in time.
Hmm. We best watch this movie together, Critic. Something tells me that all the answers to our questions may be in this peril.
Oh trust me, this film has no answers.
Speak for yourself, narc.
Oh shut up, you pretentious little-
Hey! Don't make me split myself apart!
He started it, narc.
Ugh.. let's go ahead and see if we can figure out what's going on. Let's watch the Scooby-Doo movie.
NC: So the film opens with, big shock, a Pop song!
Past NC: Yeah, but so what? The original had Pop songs, too!
NC: Yeah! And I'm sure that never dated either. Just like having Sandy Duncan or the Harlem Globetrotters!
Who?
Exactly.
NC: So after listening to,
I don't know, Scoob-Doggy-Dog. We start off with a caper going on.
Daphne: Help me!
Or, rather the end of the caper actually.
Velma: Shockingly, Daphne has been captured again. When the Luna Ghost rounds the corner with Daphne,
Shaggy and Scooby would pop out of the barrel-
Fred: -then you'll activate the conveyor belt, spilling the battered oil on the floor.
Uh.. Did we fast forward past a few scenes?
Yeah? It's weird, isn't it?
NC: They're giving you a taste of what one of the capers on the show was like,
but you wouldn't really get that, unless you grew up watching the show.
Well, I did and I think it's very clever that they're
satirizing the original showing that they have a sense of humor! By..
Making Scooby look like Marmaduke. Seriously, is that supposed to be Scooby-Doo? It barely looks like him!
Past NC: It looks more like a Gremlin that got microwaved with a bear rug!
[Shaggy and Scooby both scream in fear]
Future NC: Not to mention the crappy CGI effects.
Future NC: Tell me, did they really look THAT bad in your time period?
Past NC: Well, not this bad! But hey,
maybe it's a loving send up to the bad animation of the original show!
NC: Yeah, but the original show had an excuse for why it was bad:
Each episode had the budget of a ham sandwich and two minutes to put it together. What's this films excuse?
Past NC: Well, it is kind of neat though,
how they're making fun of their roles. Like how Daphne's the Damsel in Distress ,Velma's the smart one, Fred's full of himself. Look!
They're even mocking the pointless celebrity cameos. Uh I don't think that's mocking a pointless Celebrity cameo
I think that just is a pointless celebrity cameo. This is a victory for any celebrity who wants to make a quality
Ecologically friendly actually figure. [hey] look Michael Moore and the Jerry maguire kid come on
It's a satire of the original show and that automatically makes it funny. Show me something. That's a sad tire. That isn't automatically funny
I don't know what those are yet?
oh
Smithers [the] Creepy Janitor
[well], maybe if they keep it [going] throughout the rest of the film
But I don't know it seems like they're playing their cards pretty early if the whole film is supposed to satirize the show
Why aren't they saving these jokes for the rest of the movie? Why are they using them up in the first couple minutes?
It's spoiling the fun early for fans and confusing newcomers. It's like the Brady bunch movie
They'll have a ton of jokes like this throughout the entire I quit minute I
Was Gonna quit in like two seconds. Yeah, I quit
Well that seemed like a relatively short flick
good riddance
Well, they never did that in the show yeah even from a dramatic standpoint that seems a little early to throw it wouldn't it make
More sense that they save this for like the end of the second act or something well hey
Maybe they get right back together real Saluki
Talk about dosage
on purpose
So yeah a mere two years passes by as suddenly the owner of an amusement [park] called Spooky Island
Context and one by one and fools them all out into coming out to solve the mystery they decided to all go but not after
[establishing] that each one of them wants to solve the mystery themselves
I was gonna Solve the mystery of myself for the first time ever [are] you gonna save yourself and you get caught?
I'm a black belt now. I've transformed my body into a dangerous weapon look
Okay, I'm a little confused
I thought in the show they all liked each other did what how come they don't like each other [no] because I?
Clever no, here's fucking clever
No, no, no, I'm sorry
I just got back from the movie theater from seeing the must also will give all time the two towers [and] that had fucking Gaul
A minute [that] [is] one of the best CG characters of all time?
and yet this
abomination came out the exact same year
Are you shitting me? For God sakes Roger rabbit was better integrated than him and I'm supposed to know that. He's not really there
That is a beautiful work heart
[uh-huh]? Oh, here's a fun little fact for you
Elsa [Fisher's] in this movie. Elsa Fisher ooo that sweet honey from wedding crashers [whoo]?
[oh], you don't know where yet, but she's one of the most attractive women you'll ever see in your life
Oh my God. She is such a hobbit you mind me taking a seat there [who] the hell is that?
that s La fisher really her um
She's okay. I guess no mono. They make her like mother pretties women of all time
She's like a knockout if you say so no, and she's funny too really really funny, but he's everything [me]
I
Swear to gosh if he goes really really funny really no really she's funny and attractive
But this is really great scene where she ties fits onto a bed it puts us. What exact in his bulk
Do I have to become you it works in context?
So take a guess with the young lady who befriends scooby and shaggy is named
[no], really yes, the first thing that pops into your mind is probably correct. I'm mary Jane Mary Jane her name is actually
Mary Jane like that is my favorite name. Yeah. Oh, dude. You should totally meet her sister
pot oh
And here's another weird one. She just loves
Scooby snacks yeah, what are the odds they're 100% vegetarian and and I love [them] like me
Too I have never met another [person] who loves boobies Max me neither
It's like finding the really hot chick who loves playing video games eating hot pockets and living in your mother's house
Or the one who likes vince vaughn tied to a bed with a aachen is that words in context?
Cause the dog to discontinue any action simply flick it on the nose
[hey]
Did that dog just punch someone? Oh yeah scooby performed physical assault?
Yeah, alan is a part of my childhood feel ravaged. [oh] fuck you, asshole. [oh]
So they get to the [island] and find out that it was Mr.. Dean who called them there?
Why because not [only] does he have a mystery for them to solve?
But he wanted to see them all back together to relive that nostalgic feel there's that word again
I don't think you know the proper meaning. Uh I believe somebody is casting a spell
Students. Have you notice any difference between those arriving and those departing they look like Sober well-behaved college kids precisely
If they didn't before they came in other words a magic spell
Now wait a minute magic spells come on the original Scooby-doo made it very clear that
There's no such thing as supernatural elements in their world just a talking dog who has an appetite [for] six foot sandwiches?
Oh, thanks for being the voice of reason [no] problem
so they try to figure out what's been causing all the teenagers on the island to act so strange by looking into one of the
closed attractions
[Daphney] exit through the Entrance velma, and I will enter here through the exit there and shaggy and scooby
Do whatever you guys do I didn't think it was possible
but this fred actually [has] less of a personality than the
Original friend fact they probably just picked an actor who could already answer to his name?
Hello, normally. It's the actors chewing the scenery not the scenery chewing the app. Yes
Yeah, that's a good point even the sets have [a] little too much going on
It's hard to make much of it out to appreciate the design and the actors often get lost in it, but it's okay
It won't just drive from the pointman Slapstick. We have here
Why is this funny in a cartoon and not really here because a cartoon goes out of its way to convince you that it's alive
This film goes out of its way to convince you there's no life in it whatsoever. Wow I guess that does make sense, huh critic
panic crush
here honest
What's going on [here] where am I you're my [realm] now predict a world with no past present or future?
[poor] you [know] old friend
you
[Roger] did that [Jr.]. I figured out that [oh] guardian angel from immortal. They are
Swing just go into they [da]
Wow, so how many angels are here?
Just me
Apparently, [I] was the only one that didn't figure out angels could get murdered
thermal anomalies not [dead]
Then on that kind of dude. What good you know in this round I?
I
Don't believe you. Oh, and do you have a purgatory where you just go?
No, well, you saw like an extra knot it yeah
Tell you what why don't I just leave and you just can't enjoy hey guys critics in charge now
Yes, yes, the credit is in charge of purgatory. That's right
Just like a freakin college job who thinks he knows everything cuz you watch on MSNBC
I comprehend everything about politics, but he's never really done it [this] guy's done. Okay, so how I snapped
I'll tell you what I'll only answer yes, or no questions first time. You've asked one that isn't yes
No question you can ask anymore
Why is that? Oh my God you're just wasted. You just wasted you may give it one chance, and you've wasted
Let's go second. What do you want war on?
This one be yes or no questions. I wasn't full [deck]
You know what strip you're on your own. Oh come on
Give me a hand if all mankind is doing it at least give [me] a hand
All I can tell you is it as something to do with your review that
[you]
Why?
think of this my way of saying thanks, but
Guys the end of the world is upon us if we don't do something all mankind is doomed
[oh], what's the way to I don't know where do we go? I don't know I?
Was her anything you don't know yes it has something to do with this review
So we should just keep watching the review. Yes, okay?
Glad you brought that up who knows what we might [have] been doing if you didn't mention that
So no man fred come across a video that sort of shows the villains evil plan
Interaction between young people is polite and casual
Hey, sorry, bro. [I] will crush my bones into dust let's see how the situation should be handled
Sorry, bro
No, big whoop [dawg]? Yo, would you catch that new vid [on] the box true dat?
I'm up two stairs off on all popular trends word white people making life uncool since the dawn of time
So they figure Mr.. Bean is the culprit, but there's still an hour left of the movie
So it seems kind of unlikely, but rather than gather more clues. We have this lovely scene that we're forced to sit through
You know just for [fun]
Why don't [we] see how much every single gas joke would cost an animator to animate?
It [also] how much could have gone to a charity to stop people from watching this film?
Oh the good cause this money could have gone, [too]
Hey
Your friends did you?
Know I always get the brain worm hey look well. Let's talk into a guy for a minute
I guess that means I gotta get together at the end
[oh], please everybody knows that she's saving herself for Daphne really focusing on a mystery reminds me in the old days
We were quite a crew back then but every family has one not happy to repeat that we do oh, God
Scrappy-Doo is in this movie. I
Can't remember [who] is he again? Just one of the most annoying shit piles under squirted Kevin when I find him
I'll give him a good dose up puppy power
Shut up, oh [God]
[he's] peeing on me and as we all know there's nothing funnier in the early 2000s than a dog at urinates on Cue
Rappy I told you no urinating [on] dad. That's my job
To be fair though they do make him
Intentionally annoying in fact he's actually cast out in just a few seconds honestly. It doesn't make any sense
[I] need scooby is supposed to be his caretaker
I remember that so casting the kid to the side of the road in the middle of nowhere. Just leaving him to die
That's a pretty big asshole thing to do isn't it I mean that's downright evil for such an innocent character
What a bitch or a male bitch a little egomaniac [had] flipped his lid you don't have a stroke for this job
[Hobby] hell, if that's the case why is [that] scene even in the movie? It's only a couple seconds long
It's just an annoying bit of nothing. What's the purpose of it?
Maybe he's the villain what what [oh] the scenes only a couple ekans long?
And they're not writing a good mystery, and it's entirely pointless
Maybe that's the only point [to] having it just to make him a bad guy
No, no, it'd just be too. Stupid. It makes so little sense right I?
Think maybe we [should] keep watching the review. Yeah, let's keep going oh
I remember those supernatural elements
We said just a moment ago were never in the original show well throw over in this one [and] sadly
It looks like they can only afford one
design for these creatures which I guess is understandable all the money obviously had to go to the
scoobies
There I did my one line for the trailer now. Let's get out of here
And doesn't meet or does it look like those supernatural beings smoked a few too many Marlboro cigarettes trust me
It's not wise for supernatural beings to be smoking Marlboro cigarettes I convinced an Alien race to take up smoking once and well
Let's just say it didn't turn out well
so friggin velma get captured it's up to Daphne Scooby doo shaggy and
Mary Jane to go save them so we can defeat the creatures and save fred and velma well
That's sort of like my plan. [we'll] just get the heck out of here let the creatures eat friend [Bobo]
Okay, I never thought. I'd say this, but that was too
Cowardly honestly shaggy would run away, [but] not at the cost of sacrificing his friends
It's okay to make fun of the characters, but not when it's out of character
Shaggy will never be that cruel fred and velma always figured out everything my middle name is Judas
But they discovered [that] again through the supernatural powers. They've turned fred into more of a tool than usual man
We got beats like it was the [Liz's] on earth. No. I'm sanji well now. He's just acting like Freddie Prinze Jr.
Fred turns his teen friends against our heroes and tracks them down
Get the dog. Hey thinking [Ollie], you know
They escape and find a way into the center of [a] villains lair
Thank God. I'm so high I can't feel my a broken bones
shaggy [Tim] finds the souls of all the people who had their
Souls sucked out okay. This is really stupid and he tries to return them [to] the proper bodies
That's one part of the mystery solved the creatures must need our bodies to survive in sunlight
like a human suit
Spf one million whatever keeps you talking in that top
I am totally fine with but some of the bodies get a little mixed up. I couldn't get to my body
I didn't know where else to go. I grant it I
Can look at myself naked [ah] this movie was intended for [children] right? [I] don't [think] it was meant for anybody
Once they get their bodies back in sync. They sneak into the bad guys evil tomb where Mr. Bean who?
Apparently is captain crunch Chocula is about to [perform] an evil ceremony to steal all the islands souls
But the team knocks him out and find out who he really is
oh
Oh, man, robot actually no believe it or not. It's scrappy
puppy Power, oh
Colder child for the
lady
serious
That's right
Scrappy was the villain [the] whole time
[how] can something sound so right and you feel so wrong cuz my scrappy-Dappy-doo?
Have absorbed enough energy to rule the [world] with my all-Powerful
In a much more clever a movie this would actually be hilarious, but here. It's just kind of awkward [it] feels like last-minute
Fanfiction, it's the biggest twist since finding out Martin was the bad [guy] in secret of nimh - a real jaw dropper
Yeah, what is he transforming into Pumbaa? Hello, Timon [I've] come to eat your soul
We also get [the] end of Daphne's incredibly complex story Arc now. Who's the Damsel distress me?
Straight. I don't even get it was [danny] really captured that
Often [oh], no. I seem to remember scooby and shaggy being a more peril than her hell
I don't even scrappy had to be saved more times
I think it's more she never did anything as opposed to getting captured all the time, but yeah, it's still a little confused
But hey, they do stop the evil scrappy and his
Satanic powers of hell, [oh] God how could they not make this joke work?
Her look velma hooks up [with] that guy. She shared a sentence with call that one too and so does
Rather than Daphne that's kind of confusing yeah, were they a thing in the original show
I don't know young me uh kind of sort of not really
People always like to hint at it like maybe they had a thing going, but they never actually shared any chemistry on the show
[oh] then the movie in the shuttle has something in common. [yeah], we're in the film
Did they ever indicate they have a romantic interest and now you're telling me that technically it didn't even exist in the show
I mean does any of this satisfy any audience. What's so fucking ever?
I mean Scooby-doo is the ultimate nostalgic dream it existed long ago it exists today
It will probably continue to exist in the future whatever it is
There is just some sort of weird awkward simple charm to the original that is apparently trying to carry through
But does it work in this fucking piece of shit? Oh now? Well I know
For whatever reason Scooby-doo continues to keep going there's tons of reincarnations. There's tons of different versions
There's kind of different takes, but most of them keep what is essentially the sCooby-doo formula character?
Except for fucking this if it want to be a satire fine if [it] wanted to be [a] homage fine
But this is just a cluttered
Unfocused mess the effects are horrible the jokes fall flat and the characters aren't
Identifiable unless you watch the show and even then they're not that loyal to them
They're mostly just cardboard cutouts are stereotypes of the original characters and even then they're not really half the time
stereotypes of the original character, they're just stereotypes of
Stereotypes, it's Incredible not [only] how much this movie misses the point and the ideas of the original show
But how many different moods and Angles it's trying to attack him with and how many events don't work and worst of all making?
scrappy do the
Villains now from my point of [view] I don't remember watching the show at all
So inserting him as the bacchae makes no sense as a film on its own
Yeah, and from my standpoint
It made no sense because I know the characters and the characters would never do this
Scrappy-Doo will never be Evil Scooby-doo whenever abandoned him on the side of the street and the series [would] never be this
Mean-spirited yeah, and from my point of view it doesn't make sense because it wasn't fully developed from a comedic standpoint
Why because the movie doesn't know if it wants to be?
Mean-spirited light-hearted or both, but whatever it's trying to be
it doesn't work it just [straight-up] fails, and it's straight of
Sucks this movie can cock my ass
Much left, but temporal anomoly is taking its toll well
Yeah, it's gonna wipe us out dan. We could never figure out the answers. [oh] God how could something so horrible
Wait a minute. That's it something so horrible something, so horrible, we all sat through the horrible movie
What what do you mean the past present future [it] never managed to please anybody think about it
It doesn't mean up to the nostalgic memories of the past the current judgments of the present or the fresh thoughts of the future
It fails on all accounts, and it's destroying us all well when we do that
the only thing we can do we have to destroy it in every time period
Gnarrk
This is it no turning back
Goodbye critic Anna laughs, but as we all know all good things must come to it
Well see Roger [will] see hey scooby-doo. Where are you? I'll tell you where
gee
What happened? Did it work? Are they only in the only okay?
[the] [old] me the [young] me next you'll be worrying about your goldfish
Come on. You know. I hate them a while ago. Yes, you save humanity
once again, yeah
Awesome, bro. Yeah, [all] the world you owe me. Haha
celebrated yeah
Guess I've known good to celebrate with
Maybe this time you can do things a little different, but roger there's something. I don't understand. It's something I've never understood about film
If a movie is so bad, and everybody hates it
Then why is it still [a] big hit? Why do so many people keep watching?
Well, yeah, oh
I won't
But I will tell you there is much that awaits you
Possibly Beyond your wildest dreams come on terrified in your worst nightmare
either way
I'll be watching and always making sure you have something to critique
see
I
was really quite beautiful -
Hey, hey Rob. What are you doing getting snacks for the poker game?
Poker game, I never knew he did poker game here told you every night for the past five years you just never listened
I'm a dinosaur, but
So go to Christmas future. You're the grim reaper as well. [well] being the [angel] death is my kind of [5] job
I did every goose to Christmas future [taking] around the holidays just attack the wallet got three kids
And then I can why forgot my presents for all of us, it's nightmare
Hamid a bizarre this is indisputably true. Well, I think I'm gonna win tonight because I've been studying both your poker faces
good luck um
Is there a problem?
no, I
just
Thought I'd join you this evening of course pull up a chair
Kennedy you oh, thank you. You know I was actually quite the car player
gosh
You were always welcome
Well five-card stud nothing wild and the stars the limit
Here we already have cause
I
Can look at myself naked?